The problem that we
have studied so far
captures the essential features
of the AdWords problem,
but it can be extended
in several ways.
We will shortly talk
in some more detail
about two of these, which
relate to the idea of slates
or positions, and which relate
to the idea of personalization.
Aside from these two
extensions, there
are also many other
issues that Google
deals with on a daily basis.
One of these is related
to click-through-rates.
In particular, how does
Google know the chance
that a user clicks
on a given ad?
Google does this by analyzing
large amounts of user data
and building predictive
models, similar to those
we studied in this class, to
predict how often users click
on different ads when they're
shown with different queries.
Another issue is related
to the advertisers.
We saw earlier that the
price-per-click depends
on how the advertisers
place their bids.
So understanding the
behavior of advertisers
and incorporating this behavior
in the optimization model
is also another
important consideration.
Let's move on to discuss
the idea of slates.
In our example with AT&T,
T-Mobile, and Verizon,
we assume that the search
page for each query
has space for only one ad.
Now typically, as
we saw in Video 1
when we searched for
Nine Inch Nails tickets,
there's usually
space for many ads.
In this case,
Google has to decide
which combination
of ads, or slate,
to display with each query.
Although this would seem to
be a more complicated problem,
it can still be solved
using linear optimization.
Before, our variables
were defined
as x of a given advertiser
and a given query.
But now, we would
instead define them
as x for a given slate
and a given query.
So for example, for our wireless
service provider example,
if we had two spaces on our
results page, then for query 1,
we'd still have x_A1, x_T1, and
x_V1, where here, for example,
x_V1 is the number
of times that we
display Verizon with query 1.
But we would also have
x_AT1, x_AV1, and x_TV1.
Here, for example, x_AV1,
represents the number of times
that we display the slate
containing AT&T and Verizon
with query 1.
Now, this can become
even more complicated
as the position of the ad
within the slate is important.
For example, ads to the
right of the search results
might not attract as many
clicks as those above the search
results.
In this case, we would
also consider x_TA1, x_VA1,
and x_VT1.
And here, the first
ad in the combination
is the ad that is placed
in the first position.
So, for example,
here T-Mobile is
placed in the first
position for x_TA1
and AT&T is placed in
the second position.
We would formulate our
objective and our budget
and query constraints in
the same way as before,
but making sure that slates that
contain a certain advertiser
use up that advertiser's budget.
And slates in a
given query counts
towards that query's
estimated number of requests.
Let's now discuss the
idea of personalization.
In addition to the query,
Google can use other information
to decide which ad to display.
For example, Google might
know the geographic location
of the user as determined
from their IP address.
Google might also know
other information,
such as different Google
searches that the user has
conducted, and browser
activity on Google's website.
The question then is, how can
Google take this into account
when deciding which ads
display for which queries?
Well, just like slates, we
could also incorporate this
into our linear
optimization model.
Rather than working
with queries,
we would work with combinations
of queries and user profiles.
So rather than having
x defined for a given
advertiser and a
given query, we would
define x for a given advertiser,
a given query, and a given user
profile.
So here, a user profile just
describes the type of user.
For instance, a profile
might be men aged 20 to 25
who live in Boston,
Massachusetts in the United
States.
If we had three user profiles,
we could name them P1, P2, P3.
And then for AT&T
for query 1, we
would use x_A1P1 to
denote the number of times
that we display
AT&T's ad with query 1
for a user of profile P1.
The rest of the model could
then be easily accommodated
for this new type of
modeling consideration.
We'll just now summarize
the salient points
of this recitation.
So, so far, we've
studied a small instance
of Google's ad
allocation problem, where
we had just three advertisers
or bidders and three queries.
We saw how an optimization
solution increases revenue
by 16% over a simple
common sense solution.
What I'd like you to remember
is that in reality, this problem
is much larger.
For each query that Google
receives on its search engine,
there may be
hundreds to thousands
of advertisers bidding on it.
In terms of dollar
amounts, in 2012,
Google's total revenue
from advertising
was over $40 billion.
At this scale, the gains that
are possible from optimization
become enormous, and I
hope this convinces you
of the value of
linear optimization
in online advertising.